wenn wir jetzt darüber sprechen die
ferien beginnen früher ist natürlich
auch ein thema ob man in diesen ferien
recker gehört hatte gerade das thema
oder dass das beispiel sein peter ording
aber weihnachten das sorgt die zeit wo
man dann in den ski urlaub möchte
wörtlich und das auch ein großes thema
in den letzten tagen wir sind nicht nur
innerhalb von deutschland sondern der eu
ja da gibt es ein kampf zwischen den
verschiedenen ländern
tatsächlich hat italien angeregt das ist
ein europaweit es schief fahrverbot bis
zum oder schließungen der skigebiete bis
11 januar glaube ich geben sollte
deutschland hat sich jetzt mehr oder
weniger hinter diesen vorschlag gestellt
auch durch die mpk 16
ministerpräsidenten haben gesagt die
bundesregierung soll auch eu-weit darauf
hinwirken darauf einwirken dass das
passiert ich glaube nicht dass es dazu
kommen wird weil es bereits einzelne eu
staaten gibt die dagegen sind ich denke
es wird am ende so sein dass
insbesondere österreich zumindest
teilweise auf macht und die bedingungen
österreichs war wenn es dieses
europaweite verbot diese diese
schließung der ski pisten gibt dann muss
das eu finanziert werden auch dafür gibt
es keine mehrheit von daher glaube ich
egal was dem papier steht so wie es am
ende nicht unter man muss vielleicht zu
diesem jahr geradezu anschlag würde ich
sagen auf die österreichische
volkswirtschaft auch mal ein paar sachen
sagen wenn wir uns jetzt den sommer
angucken die sommerferien da haben uns
die italiener und die griechen über die
komplette saison qualität bei uns ist
alles sicher die griechen haben gesagt
es gibt quasi kein corona bei uns wir
haben alle gewusst dass das so ja gar
nicht stimmen kann ja und haben aber
trotzdem den sommer genossen und sind
daher in den urlaub gefahren manche von
uns sogar persönlich sehe jetzt kommt
die wintersaison ist alles ein bisschen
hart kläger und jetzt sagen wie wir den
österreicher ich frag mich da auch im
moment was für ein hässliches
gespaltenes europa erhebt sich da auf
einmal wieder jetzt sagen wir den
österreichern
sie dürfen ihre skigebiete in ihrem land
nicht öffnen wo menschen gerne in den
urlaub hinfahren und drohender implizit
mit sanktionen für deutsche die in
österreich gern ski urlaub in einen
vermutlich sehr leeren berg der im
slalom oder im schnee flug auf und
abfahren wollen dafür drohen wir jetzt
unserem nachbarland im prinzip
sanktionen oder oder oder strafen wie
erklärst du dir das das da ist ja der
bayerische ministerpräsident
vorne mit dabei zum beispiel markus
söder hat ja mit diesen genuss kommen
gleich auf markus söder und sebastian
kurz ich würde noch einen punkt machen
den wir glaube ich alle nicht vergessen
sollten
wenn wir einem land wie österreich im
ländlichen raum wenn wir überhaupt auf
die idee kommen anderen staaten in
europa als deutsche ausgerechnet ihre
volkswirtschaft zu verbieten
dann müssen wir uns nicht wundern wenn
diese wenn die menschen die davon
betroffen sind irgendwann sein wisst ihr
was die schweiz ist nicht in der eu
großbritannien ist nicht mehr in der eu
warum sollen wir uns der eu von den
deutschen sagen lassen ob wir unsere ski
pisten ob wir unseren lebensunterhalt
verdienen können und wir reden darüber
region die die hochburgen der rechts der
der rechtsextremen parteien sozusagen in
österreich sind die fpö die ländliche
gegend viel spaß mit den wahlergebnissen
wenn wir als deutsch oder einfach mal 35
prozent des bruttoinlandsprodukt
abschließen weil wir sagen der
österreicher darf seine ski pisten nicht
öffnen und zu deiner frage woher kommt
das ich habe immer zwischen sebastian
kurz dem österreichischen bundeskanzler
und markus söder dem bayerischen seinem
nachbarn sozusagen und dem bayerischen
ministerpräsidenten
eine interessante eine typische polit
freundschaft war die mögen sich
tatsächlich weil sie sich gegenseitig
habe ich das gefühl schätzen und ihren
machtinstinkt und ihre härte und
teilweise sorgen auch ihre brutalität im
politischen geschäft schätzen aber es
ist auch ein ständiger wettbewerb und
sebastian kurz hat hier und da anklingen
lassen dass er erst alles besser im
griff hat als bei uns jetzt wieder
aufmachen kann so und jetzt schlägt die
die als eine bayerische blau weiß
karierte faust sozusagen zurück da ist
und das ist das da kann man sozusagen
wenn man wie wir politik analysiert
durchaus seine freude daran haben an
diesem schauspiel aber man darf nie
vergessen weil politik von diesem
schauspiel sind immer menschen betroffen
und wir reden in österreich waren direkt
nach vorn über leute die sagen ja aber
wir leben davon dass menschen tun zum
skifahren kommen und das ist das ist was
was ich in der korona krise
grundsätzlich beobachten natürlich kommt
da die verantwortung und die sorge um
das land und die zukunft unseres landes
ganz massiv vor aber natürlich auch die
sorge um die eigene karriere und
manchmal kollidieren die beiden halt
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren